The Joe Rogan Experience the way Jerry
Seinfeld sells like he goes there's
nothing better than a pair of Levi's or
or you know or he goes uh uh a
Volkswagen Beetle or a big pen he's like
if things don't make you happy you don't
have the right things it's so funny and
I feel like he does think a little bit
like that yeah because that is a group
of person too where they're almost
spiritually connected to inanimate
objects you know like and he said this
is all going to be my new book Soulful
materialism
but
funny to me because it's like
that when you talk to them you go
oh yeah like this does mean a lot to you
that's a very funny premise though
that's a very Jerry Seinfeld it's the
best thing that's like I'm I I think his
you know I'm not familiar with all of
his comedy shows brilliant obviously His
comedy's Brilliant but that award speech
I saw was like this very unique
different thing that
he goes he goes he goes yeah these
Awards he goes he goes here's what they
really are he goes I know this award
means nothing he goes and I know that
because the last uh the last time we did
this you know the last time they had
this award show they left a bunch of
them up on stage and you all just came
up here and grabbed them he goes you
didn't earn them put it because you just
brought them home because they prop up
your meaningless lives it was the it's
the best thing I've seen it from it was
my just favorite thing
because it does seem like he's totally
raw and I feel like that is him yeah
like he is being real in that moment
where he's basically like no this is
what it is yeah yeah here's the shiny
thing he goes it doesn't matter that it
doesn't work when I get it home I want
it now he goes I want the thing on the
commercial I want to and there is
something so deeply American about that
it is disturbing on some level
but there's also a level where you got
to just recognize how powerful that
stuff is too yeah like we are one of the
only generations of people that have
experienced this level of prosperity oh
yeah which is crazy and instant access
to Goods on an app on your phone Amazon
anything you can just buy whatever you
want you can buy crazy on Amazon
very expensive things on Amazon you just
have it sent to your house it's like my
Boomer parents were like
the first heavily propagandized
generation with regard to advertising
yeah that's why we all grew up eating
because like they believed
corporations yeah corporations were like
McDonald's is it your kids are gonna
love it and you're like all right go to
McDonald's now my cousin's two kids have
never had McDonald's they're six and
four she goes they'll never she goes I
can't control them forever but for right
now they'll never have McDonald's we
grew up eating there yeah because
corporations were Paramount my father
loves commercials as much as TV shows he
will he used to call me like the
Budweiser frogs were his favorite thing
in the world remember those three frogs
on the Lily pants
wise ER and my father loved them
to him that was Art like that with the
Boomers were like one of the first
Generations where the advertising was
Art like after 9 11 Budweiser did this
commercial where all the Clydesdales
took a knee and they said from one
American and they were doing it and
you're like where was it and it's there
doing it in Jersey and you're looking at
where the towers used to be and it took
you a minute to get it and then they all
take a knee and Budweiser said from one
American icon to another and oh and my
father's a crying in the living room
going this is the greatest thing I've
seen
the bodies were still like smoldering at
my fault yeah here it is
it's crazy